welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and toss a coin to your
spoiler man as we're breaking down the
witcher nightmare of the wolf the brand
new anime is now out on netflix and it's
got a lot to unpack from it about the
law of the witcher and also where things
could be going in the future throughout
this video we're going to be going over
it from top to bottom and talking about
all the things you need to know about
its story and ending smash the thumbs up
button if you enjoy the video and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this each and every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the witcher nightmare of the
wolf
okay so similar to its live-action
counterpart nightmare of the wolf plays
somewhat with time and we follow a
character named bessemere who pulled
himself up out of poverty in order to
become a witcher long-term fans of the
series will know vesemir is being
geralt's mentor and throughout the hour
and 20 movie we learn a lot about his
past and adventures the film completely
changes how the character is often
portrayed and rather than being a
grizzled old teacher we see a selfish
and greedy man who's more interested in
gold than he is with helping people dude
really says [ __ ] them kids now this is
clearly because he grew up without any
real access to money and after getting
some from a witcher he puts himself in a
position where he can earn more
relishing it in the process as mentioned
earlier the movie jumps about from time
to time and i kind of want to discuss
stuff in chronological order so that you
can see how it all fits together i'm
gonna try and keep the plot points as
simple as possible as there are a lot of
complexities going on that we could sit
here talking about for hours however if
we look at the timeline from the top
down starting at the earliest point we
watch as vesimir lives the life of a
servant for a lord whose wife is gravely
ill with his friend ilana he goes out to
get some medicine for her but after
stealing a pie they're served a slice of
humble pie hey when they come across a
witcher named deglin deglan accompanies
them and they discover that the lord's
wife is actually possessed by amor which
he casts out and kills with help from
vesemir vesamir ends up following in his
footsteps and he sets out on the journey
to become a witcher played by theo james
he adds some real depth at the character
and seeing him not painted out in the
best light early on makes you actually
become attached to his journey the
trials are what really shapes him and
watching the brutal training that the
kids go through shows why vesamir
becomes one of the toughest witches out
there they clearly took heavy
inspiration from the spartans with
children being forced into the
wilderness and placed in the valley of
the shadow of death but vesimir survives
from this point onwards he's transformed
through the work of mages and he works
throughout the land establishing his
reputation
this kind of takes us to the opening of
the movie in which he saves a child from
a monster this creature actually speaks
which is something that's uncommon for
them and it makes vesamir realize that a
darker thing is at foot vesamir visits
alona who's now aged significantly in
comparison because of the experiments
that were carried out on him it turns
out that when she was younger she was
taken in by nobles known as desserts of
caidwin elana raised her family and she
hires vesamir to work alongside a
sorceress called tetra in order to kill
what's hunting her people along the way
they find that there are hybrid monsters
that now exist in the mountains which
are crossed between several creatures we
find kitsu which due to its bloodline
being that of an elf in ammar is able to
build reality warping illusions they
also see a new kind of basilisk and we
learn that these monsters have been
created by humans that have mastered a
certain form of alchemy the alchemy of
course exists within the witches which
we know were created in a similar way
and this is what's granted them their
long lives and powers it all traces back
to cair mohin which we learn has been
used as a place that manufactures
monsters in order for the witches to
have a constant supply of work because
the witches hunted monsters for
centuries their numbers have grown less
and less and thus deagling came up with
a plan to create more in order to make
money this very much makes vesemir
reflect on his life namely his constant
focus on cash as well as the cost that
comes with it it's a price he wasn't
willing to pay and though it seemed like
his character was always on the money
from this point you can bank on this
being the reason that the witchers
ascend into liquidation oh that was bad
now it turns out the witches made kitsu
who then made other monsters and it's
led to them having somewhat security in
their way of life
the sacking of kemoen has had a lot of
question marks surrounding it in witcher
law and we now know exactly why it
happened the witches were creating
monsters and thus people gained a reason
to turn against them this comes in the
form of tetra who wastes no time
gathering her soldiers in order to
destroy the witch's fortress with help
from kitsu they summon fourth more
monsters which ravage the castle leading
to countless character deaths this
includes the elder ryderik which i've
definitely pronounced wrong deglan and
eventually alana who travels into the
lower levels of the castle in order to
wait out the battle with the children
one of these is actually geralt as a
child who you will of course know from
the main witcher books games and show he
guides his friends out of the castle and
we'll talk about what happens to him
later on in the video akitsu uses her
illusion abilities in order to make
vesamir believe that when he's fighting
ryderick and ilana that he's actually
fighting her in tetra using altered
moments from his childhood in which he
and alana played in the snow kitsu
plagues his mind at making him believe
that she's drowning in money which of
course showcases how his greed and the
greed of the witches was their damnation
he takes a trip down memory lane and
though he's in an illusion he's faced
with the horrors of what he did when
abandoning ilana he ends up going
berserk and he badly wounds her to which
tetra arrives to finish him off in his
moment of despair deaglin is badly hurt
during the battle but he shows up in the
final moment and kills tetra before
succumbing to his wounds vesamir leaves
with alana and the pair set overlooking
a lake as she dies in his arms he
stumbles across the children namely
geralt and this very much sets the
stages for the game in which we know
that the humans were very prejudiced
towards the witches however they
somewhat need them in order to fight the
monsters in the land and we know that
because of kitsu's work that there will
be a constant supply of them now on the
flip side of this all those that know
how to turn people into witches are dead
thus vesamir is gonna have to go through
the lands in order to track someone down
who has the knowledge to do this whilst
we know the witches will return they'll
be very different to what's come before
and both besamir and geralt are more
focused on just getting by rather than
turning a massive profit that destroys
people and their land in the process
it's sort of a bittersweet moment as we
see the destruction of the witches but
much like the jedi something better
rises in their place without the more
negative aspects that they carry it's
very much a fresh start for them and
though they have a lot of work ahead of
them the darker side of the witches is
now destroyed you very much get the idea
that vesemir will become a mentor figure
now to the children as he very much
repeats the words of deglin it's a great
ending and as for my thoughts on the
film itself though it was a bit slow
paced early on it did get better the
more story that we got this actually
worked really well at filling in some of
the blank spots in the witcher timeline
and it also established a lot of
character arcs for several of our series
mainstays really enjoyed it and i
absolutely love netflix animes for this
reason there's so much that they can do
with the violence and gore that it just
makes it a blast to watch this in
castlevania was great and overall it
gets an 8 out of 10. now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the movie
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we are running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of august all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the perfect scene in the
marvel universe we talk about why i
thought entering wakanda works so well
on a number of levels and it's
definitely worth checking out right
after this if not then thank you for
sitting until the end of this one i've
been paul you've been the best i'll see
you next time take care peace